ten amazing tips to nail it was the
amazing burger gas on okay I'm using a
grill pan okay we can use a fire pan so
a grill pan get on crank that thing up
high okay always close that lit okay
keep it down that gets the max amount of
heating that but I took some blocks of
butter froze it and then grated the
butter into the burger so we get that
nice rich buttery smooth flavor inside
that delicious burger a soft butter okay
and just literally lightly brush that
butter on there that's gonna give the
Pat a really nice camera zation salt
pepper every spa nicely seasoned salt
pepper a little bit of garlic powder
okay now I'm put an egg in there okay
until Canova I like the yolk okay hold
on it's my burger yolk okay in now from
there okay and look at the egg does that
egg actually makes it a little bit
okay if you've got more time than I have
tonight they're made a little bit
thicker if you haven't then make them
nice and thin so take off a nice ball
okay almost like a sort of the size of a
tennis ball and then literally start
shaping those burgers like that
now look dude hands around and just
literally place that
[Music]
protect the bun I've got some nice fresh
arugula and because of the fatty
richness of his burger
it doesn't need dressing so I put the
arugula on there to help protect the
bread and give that nice little peppery
flavor now I want to sprinkle some of
the chopped bacon on
and the restaurant on tomatoes so this
is a really nice crispy bacon place with
a crispy bacon topic
and the seat behind these pates is do
not keep on flipping them okay the more
you flip them okay the more they're
gonna break
these on their okay put that on okay
bring that to the side and just to get
that cheese melting okay I take a little
bit of butter and I sort of crate a
little bit of sort of extra flavor with
a butter underneath and that's gonna
give it so much flavor but look get a
pan and put the pan on and just stick
that on top there right now that will
help out the cheap just quickly my
burger over to there that's nice and
juicy so put the burgers up there to
rest they'll continue cooking olive oil
salt pepper I want to toast the buns
that protects the actual burger had
stopped the whole thing to be coming
sorry
[Music]